I believe the world is a different shape
than what we were taught in those
programming centers which is called
public school system now the edge which
keeps all the oceans in is a 150-foot
ice wall which is Antarctica now
yesterday the son of the moon was in the
sky at the same time which is not
possible in my belief one igloo enough
to build a missile from scratch yet
stupid enough to climb inside my kind of
crazy that's mad Mike and he attempted
to challenger himself into space without
such a zero clearance to do so to see if
the earth was flat with Zone two eyes
twice flat earthers doubt that the Earth
revolves around a star in the galaxy a
hundred thousand light-years wide which
has been traveling at 242 miles per
second for thirteen billion year ok fine
starting to see their point as we all
know scientific facts are completely
debatable if science is so smart how
come it still hasn't beaten cancer or
the hiccups the only thing that's ever
done is make that milf Kylie look
reasonably hot people who don't trust
science are the backbone of this country
Mad Mike doesn't run computer
simulations or do math like some
he boldly went where everyone that can
afford a plane ticket has gone before
it's the coolest most dangerous thing
I've seen in 10 years of doing this show
which is why I launched that DIY
astronaut to Planet Hollywood for this
week's ce-web-rity profile
[Applause]
hey Mike get over here you lunatic
Daniel this looks nothing like your show
on TV that's the game here in Hollywood
it's all fake
some of the biggest hoaxes in history
were shot on this stage Game of Thrones
the assassination of JFK Benghazi I knew
it what about 9/11
no that wasn't us okay believe that was
shot up in Vancouver now how old are you
mask 62 and how many times have you
climbed inside of a rocket - and I'm the
only guy in history to design build and
then launch himself in his own rock are
you legally allowed to leave Earth you
know we'd plan to keep it to FAA and
whatever else but you know I'm not to
that point yet where it's a two million
dollar venture to get me to space how
much have you raised so far I think I
got about 87 dollars in my pocket so
it's going a little slow do they find
you do are you allowed you're not
allowed to launch a rocket they don't
want me launching it from my backyard
they want people quarter-mile away from
it they want the airport's notified and
you notify the airports you do all of
that usually have you been a risk taker
your entire life well I've been married
a couple of times I don't know they did
a couple of women that it's probably
pretty questionable morals when I used
to pick up women and clubs uh-huh I used
to use neurolinguistics was just study
of eye patterns and body movements I
would use that but I would use the gooey
theory and that is go ugly early you'd
like to buy many drinks and you always
get laid by 10 o'clock that night you go
back on again I must say it's gonna work
for everybody no no but that's a solid
theory more bang for your buck I used to
have a bad prom I used to pick up women
I would like when it's asleep I'd read
right on him with a permanent magic
marker huh they couldn't know it - they
got home the next day taking a shower
look away what's going back there that
doesn't seem like a hobby as much as it
does assault what's the game plan you're
planning to get to the apex of the
height and then just eyeball it out the
window
and like oh yeah the earth is round and
then come back down I never said that I
was gonna try to prove the Flat Earth at
1,800 feet I mean that's a goof even
that's goofy in my books okay okay
it was just supposed to raise awareness
to get me the space to prove what shape
this planet is I believe it's stationary
motionless and I believe it is flattened
I believe you
don't believe that and you just want a
free trip to space a lot of people think
that uh-huh but I believed in my first
black ball so I don't know if I had her
here right now would she be shocked that
you're shooting yourself into space
or would she say that's about right I'd
like to see her tits again they were
incredible listen nothing's better than
history nothing's better than history
yeah the thing yes everything has an
expiration date mm-hmm and once the
gravy train has been formed okay I mean
man you don't long I've been doing this
show 10 years choo choo yeah I know man
it's probably got the direct deposit
though so you don't need to get the
Kachinas direct deposit really
convenient though you don't like I don't
trust banks you don't trust banks
oh no no where do you want me to put my
money I'm being honest I would think
putting mad Mac in space for two million
dollars you better make that
a two-seater and I want to
sit in front and I don't want to sit
behind you cuz I don't want the last
thing of us going into earth is me
penetrating through you yeah I don't
like the thought of that I made a globe
I think you'll like it
okay it's a hundred percent accurate I'm
still working out some of the kinks the
obvious problem that's on an axis and
this world is not on an axis but how
else am I gonna get it to you know why
spin I think that to trim the edges
that's probably not to scale either no
this is to scale it is to scale well at
least I printed it out do you believe in
gravity no I don't believe in gravity if
we live on a globe those poor people in
Australia are hanging upside down and
gravity is holding all this water
some people believe in a globe or
telling me now there's no up and down on
the globe there's up and down when I'm
with my girlfriend you want to mean
always back to the thrusting I'm sorry
that's part of my life what would it
take for me to convince you that the
world is round I don't believe anyone
can bench me the world is round because
they have no proof I can't believe in
the Easter Bunny if I want to no you
can't not a piss aid yes silly what you
ever seen the Queen of England not
personally okay then does she exist I
don't know you're seeing grandma porn
I've never seen it but I know it exists
I actually want to watch it but I don't
want to look it up on my computer I bet
you've never seen the face of a sexually
satisfied woman
burn
[Laughter]
do you call round earthers globe tardes
you know here's the thing in our lives
we need to quit fighting with each other
cause that's what the governments and
every one thing when they want us all
fighting about you know what sports team
you like are you public and are you
Democrat are you perhaps your Diet Pepsi
if way nobody's fighting over Pepsi or
dying baby
no I'm a Sam's Cola guy myself really
bulk nasty gotta save money okay then go
get a $20 hooker understand me once they
might go to Vegas without her and they
actually do pot cheaper there on Monday
morning what's the cheapest hooker
you've ever slept with
I'm not saying either way I'm saying
that's your business but I respect it I
spend $500 for hand job in Vegas once oh
my brother said he needed the money
man Mikey done that was funny
turns out you don't need to be a rocket
scientist to build a rocket technically
mine is just a firework that you can
ride a little worried about the report I
don't see any safety equipment you know
and I'm all about safety that's pretty
evident right because I want to live
through this thing hey I want to see my
cats grow up and you don't see the
grandkids and stuff like that okay
that's weird are you doing any
modifications to the rocket how
different is the next rocket gonna be it
will be bigger I know what keep asking
me to keep getting bigger I don't know
I'm not gonna answer that question
anymore
okay probably will be Mike you probably
think I'm gonna help you with your
rocket but going up isn't the way you
prove the earth is flat it's going down
see the earth is only two to three feet
deep in any particular place so you're
telling me you found a spot three foot
deep two to three feet okay easy now
grab my ankles let's see what's down
there ah it's space alright crawl space
whose rat everywhere well kiss my
taint that's all the proof I need
smells like Satan's Jack's yack down
here pull me up
expecting a guy to be so horny in this
current climate maybe it's a good time
for him to leave the planet